they'll take swings against the 27 year
old former a.l cy young award winner
blake snell blake's uh would like to get
back on track and so would the raise
like to see him get back on track as he
goes to work on aaron judge now
full count pitch and the breaking ball
freezes him and catches him looking
got him with that same curve ball that
he struck at judge looking stanton now
with the runner aboarding two gone
swings through 96. so walking three
strikeouts and these rays taking swings
against the two-time all-star
31-year-old veteran masahiro tanaka two
and two the count of meadows
and a ground ball to second you had
identified this matchup meadows versus
tanaka before the game started
another pitch on the outside corner to a
left-handed batter and it's the same
result a ground out to the right side of
the infield
here's g-man choi now with the two-out
base runner just two for his last 21.
troy pops it up
rochelle is all by himself
everyone's trying to hit homers good
luck on a pitch up there
did you hold up he did not on the appeal
down to the first base up fire hunter
wendell stead has four straight
strikeouts for snell turn into an rbi
opportunity now the runner in scoring
position down and over
to strikeout aaron judge
sanchez setting up on the corner and
that's where they get him to fish first
strike out of the game for
if blake snell is is ready
to go seven eight innings he's staying
in there but obviously he's not this is
how you would have to beat the yankees i
think when you're going to think about
their lineup
boy with a hot smash for diaz who makes
a nice play throw to first on a
convenient hop for joy and the yankees
go down in order
second strike out of the game from
masahiro tanaka as he takes care of lao
[Music]
tzanaka strikes him out still the
scoreless ball game in this series
opener from the drop
in the air to right center
but playable for meadows and two away
chopper
and another one two three innings six up
six down for andrew kidridge
been a well-pitched affair and masahiro
tanaka four scoreless innings on the
mound for the yankees
struck him out and the strikeouts are
coming now second time through the
lineup for tanaka
three-pitch strikeout for tanaka who is
dealer and peter fairbanks takes over on
the mound for tampa yankees looking for
their first hit tonight
flips a breaking ball up there to
talkman who swings right through it in
the strikeout for pete burbank here's
their first hit of the ball game
[Applause]
this is the latest into a game this
season that the yankees have collected
their first hit one out in the sixth
judge poached that back up the middle
and the rays are able to turn the double
play kevin kiermeier leads things off in
the raised half of the sixth it's the
bottom of the order against a new yankee
pitcher right-hander louise sesson
it's been a good matchup for kevin
kiermeier over the years five for 15
against luis sessa and that success
continues leading things off in the
sixth
tampa's got its first runner in scoring
position tonight here meyer at third is
as far along on the base paths as
anybody's been all night tonight it'll
be up to brandon lau now with two
he gone away with one there and the
hitter knew it wow
a scoreless game in the top of the
seventh
sends a fly ball out to shallow right
meadows coming on for it and slides to
make the catch
that's a good play they were shaded way
across and meadows came a long way to
get that gary sanchez tonight has walked
and grounded at second base biggest
at-bat of the night on either side of
the scorecard right here
challenge fastball center cut
0-1
another one fouled away at 2-2
three fastballs good morning good
afternoon good night the yankees
can find a way to push a runner over and
then get him in
talkman at second with nobody out as the
go-ahead run lemay hew bounces it to
shortstop they'll go for the lead man
and get him
he was going right away trying to get
the perfect jump and said i'll take a
perfect throw or to get me well that was
close too and it did take a perfect
throw so runners at first and second now
for the birthday boy pinch hitting mike
perez
runners aboard with one god and that one
gets away from sanchez two runners in
scoring position now
because adevino didn't throw it close
enough to the target
now the rays with their best scoring
chance here we go one two
swinging a drive out to center field
hicks sets up makes the catch zadzugo
tags up he'll come in and score
and mike perez on his birthday has
driven in the first run of the night
should carlos stan leads things off for
new york as chas row looks to close
things down
that one's playable
and there's one gun luke now
got him one more out ray start their
series in a positive way
[Music]
and that should do it
popped into center field for kiermeier
and the rey steel one to start this four
game series